the Trump crony pardon list is growing quickly.
I had 15 or so names for you yesterday that
were moderately croney a stick, but.
Today's list, while smaller, is way more erroneous
that Donald Trump has now pardoned Jared Kushner's
dad, Charles Kushner.
Remember, Trump's daughter is Ivanka Ivanka,
married to Jared.
Jared is not just Trump's son in law, but
also an adviser.
And Jared's dad, Charles Kushner, was previously
convicted for hiding personal political contributions
through organizations for tax evasion and
for witness tampering.
It's quite a slate of crimes, and the witness
tampering charge is wild.
Jared Kushner's dad, Charles Kushner, hired
a prostitute that he knew what it means, that
he knew her.
It's not clear he knew a prostitute hired
her to seduce his own brother in law, set
up a recording system for the whole thing,
and then sent the tape to his sister.
He was ultimately sentenced for two years,
served 14 months, then went to a halfway house
and was disbarred.
Big fiasco.
So Trump pardoned him, essentially a family
member by marriage.
Trump also pardoned Paul Manafort and Roger
Stone, both convicted in the Trump Russia
investigation.
Both, quote, stayed loyal, as they say, didn't
give up any info on Trump.
So they got pardoned specifically after helping
to keep Donald Trump out of harm's way, exactly
as we thought they would when Stone and Manafort
got pulled into the investigation years ago.
And then less prominently, Trump added pardons
for 23 other people yesterday and three sentence
commutations as well.
So are we surprised that Donald Trump is pardoning
friends and cronies?
No, of course not.
Is there a bigger question about presidential
pardons that goes beyond Trump?
No doubt.
No doubt about it.
But the way that Donald Trump is using his
pardon power is so crony stick that even some
Republicans are saying this is not good.
Republican Senator Ben Sasse from Nebraska
said, quote, This is rotten to the core.
Now to everybody saying to me on Twitter and
elsewhere that hold on a second.
Obama also pardoned people.
Yes, Obama pardoned many people.
But there's a key difference, which is that
so far the majority of Trump's pardons are
either people directly connected to him or
whose crimes were connected to helping him.
That's not the same as Obama.
There's a debate about pardons to be had.
Let's not pretend that what Donald Trump has
done with pardons is the same as what Barack
Obama did of the 65 pardons and commutations
that Trump had granted before yesterday, 60
went to people either with a personal tie
to Donald Trump or whose crimes specifically
helped Trump's political goals or helped to
protect Donald Trump.
So that's different.
Now, Trump and other Trump loyalists have
insisted the president's pardon power is absolute.
And in a general sense, that's absolutely
true.
The pardon power is absolute.
But remember that Trump dangled a pardon for
Paul Manafort during Manafort prosecution.
That's part of the obstruction that Robert
Mueller was looking at, among other instances.
Recall that during Paul Manafort trial, Trump
publicly praised Manafort, didn't rule out
a pardon even as the trial was ongoing, and
then said Manafort was brave for refusing
to break and that flipping almost ought to
be outlawed.
And then, of course, bigger picture.
The the other tragedy with this is that there
are really at least thousands of people, maybe
tens of thousands, I don't know, not Trump's
cronies, but just regular people mistreated
by the justice system who could really benefit
from pardons.
And Trump is throwing in a few pardons for
people serving long jail sentences for drug
charges, for example.
But it's really symbolic and meaningless systemically
and structurally.
And if Trump really wanted to do something
good with this pardon power, look at the hundreds
or even thousands of people bullied unfairly
by the justice system, convicted for drug
crimes which have now ruined their employment
prospects.
Who could really benefit from a pardon?
So always with Trump, it's not just the cronyism
stuff and the nepotism, but there's almost
always a missed opportunity to actually use
his power for good.
Expect even more pardons.
We're still waiting to see whether the preemptive
pardons happen for his family, for Rudy Giuliani
and others, that may not be until January.
If it does happen on January 1st.
Huge membership special to kick off the year.
If you've been thinking of getting a membership,
get on my newsletter at David Pakman Dotcom.
You will get a perfect email on the first
telling you how to sign up The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman dot com.